hey what's up Samuel leaves here and I'm
actually just take time visiting some of
my old hometowns
places where I've lived grow up I
started off investing and a lot of you
will know that now I've moved to London
so all our offices are in London and I
live in Buckinghamshire the thing is I
mean one of the reasons that I moved one
of the reasons we'll say that I think
that if you systemize if you systemize
your portfolio if you live really close
to your investment houses even they
don't have fee you'll kind of feel like
you you get roped into the management
side of stuff so one of the reasons I so
happily moved to London was because I
just wanted it I didn't want to ever
have to visit the houses I wanted I
wanted to force myself to put such a
good systems in place I mean did you
system once your property is pretty well
yeah and I think it's really important
so I still like to come down just to
walk around and remember where I came
from sometimes you know I'm in Walsall
right now she's Warsaw centre I used to
walk down here pretty much every day I
went to school in Warsaw I used to work
in Warsaw I mean you've not been too
impressed with Warsaw yet you reckon you
know honestly that I used to work around
here I actually used to work in that
building just build him right here I
used to come here I used when I was 16
years old I used to clean snooker tables
so crazy this was called Reilly's before
I used to clean snooker tables here when
I was 16 years old just cuz I was
hustling I was doing anything just to
get some extra money
I was plastering I was working for my
dad can you play some I can clean
snooker tables be a while but you know
what's so crazy
this is the build amazed to worker every
day I'll remember nice to work here nice
to think cuz obviously you know it's not
it's a great job they're clean steel
tables it's not a great building at the
time I was just pleased to gets the
money but I managed to think man imagine
in this building that would be amazing
that was like the dream you know some of
the things that were the dream fast
forward 12 years I mean when I was 16
years old will keep working and sneaking
snooker tables I was not very popular I
didn't really have any friends and now I
mean I was single now I've got not only
a beautiful family beautiful kids great
friends you know mates and friends I
could buy this building I could buy this
building and this building and I
wouldn't even man I wouldn't even notice
I wouldn't even hardly notice the dent
in my bank and I know that sounds like a
jerkish thing to say but it's just it's
just mind-blowing what can change in 12
years
I'm 28 now and I know you probably you
probably think I'm a dick saying that
risk you know what I think I remember
over just over a year ago I messaged you
on Facebook I remember this but you
remember unless you on Facebook just
over a year and I was like when's the
next class gonna be near me and I told
you where I was and you were like you
didn't say hello you decide just get to
the next crash course and I for yes it
travel you know you in Belper yeah and
when's the next when's the next training
you dude in Belfast and I said just stop
playing and just get to the new year
first of all for this guys I don't want
to know anymore
I'm having the speech live me on YouTube
but you I was like arrogant or something
yeah it's easy to kind of Judge wealthy
people and think Oh they've got all the
money in the world you know they're
there they're rich they're successful to
keep it all for themselves but I dunno I
think I just took your advice because I
don't know what nothing else to do and I
had to do it so I went to the crash
course and then I realized that you know
now you've got all the knowledge all the
wealth or to success brilliant you sous
chef you know what and how are you
I'm financially free financially for you
working as a DJ yeah I was cleaning I
was killing snooker tables I think that
what can happen in 12 years people I
mean people people underestimate what
can happen in 12 months because I think
a lot can have a lot happen for you in
12 months but people say you know
they're like 16 in there saying oh when
I'm 65 I want to be financially secure
or what I retire at 45 listen man you
can have it all and you can what do you
think if you just think medium term or
long term and I'm talking in long term
I'm a 28 year old I'm pinching myself
even so I was walking around here I know
we've been looking I've been pointing
out yeah driving around yeah it's crazy
it's a toy since Florentine you go we're
walking for any life so this one grew up
this ways to live but I own this
apartment here I've got this Papa daily
sorry it's just my blonde man but I
think I never thought that would happen
I never thought I'd be able to you know
I mean I in houses and apartments all
over the place around here and I just
think but also remember where you came
from like when you and no one's self
made you know I'm here because I've been
helped I've been trained I've been
mentored all those people have helped me
put properties when I was too young to
get a mortgage my first property my
stepdad put it in his name for me he was
like a guarantor you've been helped
no no one self-made and I think no
matter how wealthy you become now I'm
wealthy I literally could buy these
buildings and honestly it wouldn't yeah
but but the thing is remember where you
came from remain humble and it's good
this must just take a walk around I
think you're old you're Old Town's I
have to come here but and what you can
achieve
I mean those people people even when
they're 60 that I'm 60 years old or too
old man if you're 60 years old you got
you still got good 10 20 years left of
of energy and strength you can change
the world when you're 60 years old and
what you might lack in in the same kind
of energy that our 20-year old retired
you make up an experience if you're 16
years old you've got just the time is
now the time is now
excuse Kellerman Ricky's killing it it's
definitely I think anyone watching this
is thinking
- no I want to do well in probably
weather listen get first we'll get
educated yeah and second of all surround
yourself with positive like-minded
people the average of the five people
spend most farmers which is why I to
spend my time with people like Samuel
because I want to be just as successful
as em I want to be like them I want to I
want to have what they have and you know
people like that inspire me yeah and you
know I could walk around now and I can
this video and I could point out to all
my houses the different properties how
much they're making but I don't want
this to be about men right now I want
this to be about you so just just just
think massive you know whatever you
doing right now if you clean the snooker
tables whatever you're doing it's where
you are right now is not bad but if you
know that you've got potential for way
more just dream big and go make it
happen and hopefully I can be the
inspiration of that those people hate on
me cuz they're like oh man showing off
whatever that's not my heart not trying
to show off I just work this guy was
trying to keep it all for himself why
would he share it with other people
I just want to inspire people as to as
possible and help educate tomorrow I'm
running tomorrow I'm in the village
hotel in Warsaw and I'm just gonna be
sat around a table taking people helping
people that have started it nothing
helped and becoming financially free
giving them sharing everything all the
strategies I've done so honestly as many
people succeed as possible if you're
watching this and you and you have
become successful if you're painting
yourself at your success and it's been
as a result of my training on my help
then I want you to head down to WWE
winners on a Wednesday comm I'll leave
the link in the description and I'd love
to meet you and I'd love to celebrate
your success
I'd love to even get you on my youtube
channel and share your story as well
because the more people the more people
that I can inspire to be successful and
then if you'll do the same and inspire
people to be successful and together one
day at a time will change the world we
will see everyone wants in this video
and the winners on the Wednesday I'll
also leave a link below for the property
investors crash course as well free
train in two days completely free on the
house why because your success is my
oxygen cheesy as it sounds it's true man
I'll see you around don't forget to like
the video or dislike it I don't mind
just uh just do something subscribe
comment and we'll keep walking around
bless you man thanks for watching
we've been moving around literally
haven't read the penny and very good
night and it's kind of like money
doesn't buy happiness the best things in
life are free
the might as well cost the earth you
haven't got time to enjoy them you can
scroll through the winners Wednesday's
stories
different people different genders
different ages different races different
backgrounds different colors different
motives different go different places
one thing in common
prepared to do what it takes coachable
follow the training die afterward I'm
gonna whip up a revolution right now
this is a revolution boy and in two
years time three years paulien blood do
you remember those were the days